hi my name is Chelsea and I'm an MIT
sophomore studying computer science and
molecular biology and I'm here to
explain to you how websites are built so
when we're looking at a website that
you're trying to visit there are two
computers we care about there's you
sometimes called the client side and
there's them the server side the website
you're trying to access so when you're
browsing the Internet you type in a URL
like facebook.com/ and you send a
request to a computer that Facebook owns
once it gets there Facebook has a bunch
of things that it needs to do first of
all it has a database a database is kind
of like a bookshelf containing books
about all of the users of Facebook so
they'll have a book about you it's got
information about your friends and your
posts your likes and your comments maybe
it has a picture of you and all of this
is stored in the database
next the information from the database
goes through the website code which is
what all of the programmers at Facebook
pour all of their effort and time into
making and the website code generates
something called an HTML file
hTML is a bunch of code in another
language which describes exactly how the
layout of the website is going to be
once it reaches you so now that they
have this file containing all of the
HTML the JavaScript etc it's passed back
through the internet and arrives at you
we're a software program called the
browser which you're already using to
explore the web we'll take the HTML file
and render it into something that looks
pretty such as your Facebook homepage as
it was meant to be and once it's there
you can click view source from the
browser and see what the original HTML
was meant to look like so yeah that's
how websites are built from them all the
way up to you